on s'est parlé avant la conférence de
presse et vous disiez un peu ce qu'on
vienne où vient de vous entendre le dire
vous êtes politiquement ça donne un coup
c'est un peu politiquement la fin de la
récréation mais même juridiquement
monsieur taillon des pouvoirs accrus aux
policiers sont quand même important on
peut enlever les permis
fermé des comptes de banques obligées un
remorqueur aller chercher parce que y'a
pas là des outils supplémentaires pour
les policiers
en vérité on ne sait pas ce dont les
policiers sont capables dans cette crise
puisqu'on les a pas vraiment
laissé travailler depuis le début alors
ce qui est certain c'est que l'état
d'urgence ça va permettre de créer de
nouvelles interdictions mais il y avait
déjà des choses qui étaient interdites
et que les manifestants ne respectaient
pas l'ovalie sculpté de manière
temporaire un peu plus ciblés on entend
l'interdiction de manifester postes
frontaliers dans un aéroport bon dans
certains lieux du droit ordinaire
prévoyait probablement déjà cela mais ça
va rendre les choses très explicite donc
ça va être utile mais là où le
gouvernement trudeau et sera rapidement
sur la défensive c'est que les critères
pour mobiliser cette loi on met la barre
très haute la loi est très exigeante et
elle exige de démontrer que on n'avait
pas suffisamment d'outils juridiques
or c'est difficile de dire il manquait
des outils dans le corps quand depuis
deux semaines on a utilisé aucun des
outils à la disposition et même été
nécessaire que des citoyens de la région
d'ottawa demande une injonction parce
que les autorités publiques ne demandez
pas ils savent être difficile de prouver
que le coffre à outils étaient
suffisants quant à windsor ou à québec
on a fait la preuve que l'isu qui
normaux pouvait produire des résultats
vous vous dites ils n'ont pas faim le
gouvernement n'a pas fait la preuve
d'avoir épuisé tous les recours normaux
avant d'arriver avec l'acception c'est
l'argument que les oppose à ce que vont
vouloir contester cet état d'urgence
vont bon mobilisés et c'est un peu
normal parce que le gouvernement était
passé fait un début de crise pour de
bonnes raisons de nobles raisons les
scellés le droit de manifester et pour
des raisons tactiques laisser
l'opposition se diviser sur un sujet qui
polarise ans à l'intérieur du parti
conservateur mais là ça veut ça prend un
signal un effet d'ultimatum pour
vraiment dire la crise est finie je
pense que c'est d'abord ce besoin mais
que cherche à combler l'état d'urgence
mais d'eau dans les non-dits ce qu'on
peut comprendre aussi c'est que comme la
police d'ottawa a pas bien fait son
travail je pense qu'on peut s'entendre
là-dessus c'est un fait les nouveaux
pouvoirs exceptionnels peuvent donner à
la grc des pouvoirs dans une juridiction
municipale comme à ottawa et que la grc
pourrait pallier plus facilement au
manque
de force de la police d'ottawa est là
pouvoirs d'urgence à ottawa il permet au
fonds de faire fi des histoires de
compétences a alors à 20 dans les
derniers jours on avait une chicane des
compétences on se renvoyer la balle pour
ça c'est pas moi c'est l'autre qui
devrait agir à partir de maintenant le
le la police fédérale on rend les pleins
pouvoirs et pourra agir et propus cacher
derrière le fait c'est à la police
d'ottawa d'âgés et c'est vrai que dans
le cas précis de la ville d'ottawa c'est
un peu compliqué parce que il ya des
terrains des rues qui sont de compétence
fédérale et d'autres qui sont de
compétence municipale ce sera un gros
problème quand il ya de la volonté puis
de la coopération
mais là il semble qu'on va on va aller
au delà de cela mais vous oubliez que la
loi exige de consulter les provinces et
là il ya plusieurs provinces qui s'y
opposent il faudra voir si le
gouvernement s'entête à appliquer son
état d'urgence dans des provinces qui
n'en veulent pas pour l'instant le point
de presse laissent entendre qu'on va
agir surtout dans les compétences
fédérales les postes frontaliers les
aéroports donc l'oeil ça va et on est
dans des enclaves fédéral et dans la
province de l'ontario qui elle semble
vouloir de cet état d'urgence pour
sortir de la crise mais enfin vous
faudra être très attentifs est-ce qu'on
essaie d'appliquer un état d'urgence à
la saskatchewan où aller au nouveau
brunswick au québec alors qu'ils n'en
veulent pas ça sera une pente glissante
pour le matelot la réponse
trudeau est à dire ça s'applique partout
au canada mais les provinces qui n'ont
pas besoin parce que leur police il n'y
a pas de 40 si vous voulez ils
utiliseront pop c'est tout le stop et
salace à répondre que vous en pensez
mais le partout au canada dans les
compétences fédérales ça va bien il ya
des aéroport fédéraux en territoire
québécois et c'est normal que la loi s'y
applique mais effectivement il n'y a pas
lieu de donner la gestion des manifs des
manifestations à une police fédérale
alors qu'il ya pas de problème puisque
les provinces sont parents demandent
donc la loi est très claire là dessus il
faut que les provinces soient consultés
et il faut que la province soit dans
l'incapacité d'agir pour ce que quand
tout le monde est d'accord ça va très
bien pour démontrer qu'ils ont un besoin
mais là du moment où il ya des provinces
qui disent n'y a pas de besoin pille on
n'en veut pas fait ça deviendra demain
plus difficile mais monsieur taillon
dans la vraie vie on parle de l'ontario
peut-être l'alberta à côte mais
l'ontario à windsor et ottawa qui ont
pas réussi à gérer ça le québec il ya
une manifestation ça s'est plutôt bien
déroulé l'ontario ne peut pas plaider
qu'ils avaient parfaitement le contrôle
de tout le nom mais à windsor l'ontario
a fait la démonstration de vendredi à
dimanche que leurs outils étaient
suffisants mais le gouvernement ontarien
pas fait la même démarche dans la ville
d'ottawa et chose certaine il semble
vouloir de cet état d'urgence il semble
vouloir coopérer donc je pense que pour
résoudre la crise en ontario dans la
région de tahoua ça va plutôt bien coco
coopérer c'est dans les autres provinces
et si on cherchait à l'appliquer à des
lieux qui ne sont pas de compétence
fédérale que l'on pourrait s'embarquer
dans une situation délicate et ou s'ils
vont pas oublier c'est un état d'urgence
qui veut qu'ils aient beaucoup plus
encadré qu'au niveau provincial et donc
la chambre des communes va jouer un rôle
important du 17 jours et nul doute que
l'opposition officielle et peut-être
même les autres partis le bloc risque
d'être tout autant contre la chose que
le premier ministre du québec pendant
voir le npd les libéraux sont
minoritaires
que cette impression de la chambre des
communes va aussi coloré la crise faudra
voir la réaction des conservateurs était
connu en tout cas mais le npd a dit
qu'ils allaient appuyer la démarche donc
ils ont la majorité pour cela patrick
taillon merci on va reparler laissé en
vigueur 30 jours avant que ça soit re re
appliquée merci beaucoup envoyez vos
merci au revoir